how was your first sit down with uh
president clinton
well we uh we really didn't uh
sit down uh uh it uh it happened very
quickly uh
president clinton uh
chatted with me uh at the inauguration
uh ceremony for a few seconds
uh that's about it yeah i i heard
you tell a joke one time you said you
know in the two years of me being the
director of cia you know the plane that
tried to fly into the pentagon or white
house that was actually me trying to get
a meeting with the president because you
he wouldn't sit down with you well
that's basically true uh bill clinton
was
once is a speed reader and uh so
he didn't want to sit down every morning
and have the director of central
intelligence
read sheets of paper to him uh he can
he could read a lot faster himself and
so
he uh would just let the system
operate in his speed reader so
occasionally you wouldn't know what he
was
reading but i remember one time he said
jim have you
read that new book uh
on africa by so and so
um what did you think of it and i i
happily had read it
uh but uh he was reading a lot of books
as
president and uh uh talking to people
about
but uh it wasn't very formal and he
didn't he didn't want there to
be any nod toward
toward having a system of
reviewing is that is that a protocol
like typically
the president's first meetings to get a
briefing by the director of cia every
morning is that typically historically
what it's been what's been the case or
no
it's happened and it has been the case
several times i think but it's it's
there's nothing
required about it the president uh
designates the director as director and
the director
uh gets briefed on this
[Music]
kind of panoply of the briefs and then
starts
or started the meeting uh with the
president the next
day and but that's that changed
uh in part with me yeah that's what i
wonder i mean if you're a president you
would want to meet with the director of
cia to kind of see what's going on if
it's not once a day maybe once a week to
just kind of be briefed
uh especially when you're saying two
years you never got a chance to meet
with them
uh were you reporting that kind of like
you know how you run a company and
sometimes you put your org chart
together and you say look
i'm the ceo i have the cfo the ceo the
cio the cto whatever and i got five
direct reports typically the ceo doesn't
want to have more than five reports
sometimes it's seven but let's just say
five symmetrical number
were you reporting to the chief of staff
did he want you to go through another
layer before you go through him who were
you directly reporting to
functionally yes chief of staff
uh and he uh he liked it the president
would report to him and that was
kind of the way it worked out it wasn't
absolutely a rule
and when we would go in together
uh tony and i to
say something uh to the president i
was it was okay with them as we walked
out if i stopped by the president's desk
and said
mr president you want to pay particular
attention to x and y
the report today it was that sort of
thing was fine
got it so day before you became the
director of cia versus the day after the
day you became a director of cia
what were some of your responsibilities
how dramatically did your
responsibilities change the day after
becoming the
director of cia well i think the
main change uh is the change
from being just a reporter of
intelligence to being
in a situation where you can recommend
and sometimes get approved
covert actions a covert action uh
is an event that's put together in order
to try to influence
what the policy is rather than just
report on it
and it's not there's nothing sneaky
about it from the point of view of the
president not knowing about it the
president
fully briefed and he gets a signed
recommendation
uh for from the director and
uh it all is proper and done
but it um is it it's an
action item and that sometimes those are
successful and sometimes they're not and
uh
bill clinton was very
uh disturbed and he said one time in a
close meeting um that he had not
gone into rwanda and
uh stopped the hutus killing of the
other rwandan tribes it was
really the tootsies were massacred
essentially
during the rwanda killing fields of
eight to 93 94.
and um that
what i think president clinton didn't
want to have is that he did not want
another
uh event like the black hawk down
where american troops got killed on the
ground in
somalia and and so he was being very
cautious
and he did not stop the uh rwandan
uh hutus from killing the tutsis and he
was very
as he thought about it over time he
decided that had been a big mistake
and he would often tell people and this
is one thing i i rather admire about
clinton he would tell people okay
you need to know the biggest mistake i
made as
president it was going not going in
and protecting the tootsies i should
never have let them massacre the hutus
um and most all presidents don't do
things like that
they don't say write out in the national
security council meeting you know i made
a big mistake and here's what it was
because that was close to a million
people that died um as a result of that
decision of his and it's um
something that uh has come up in
time a number of circumstances uh but
uh it's um an important issue and and
it's something that he had the manhood
and grace to uh
to deal with uh straightforwardly was
was that during your time when a million
people died during his watch was it when
you were his director of ci or was it
afterwards
uh it was largely uh
during about 94
and i was director in 93 to 95.
got it do you think it could have been
prevented if he was communicating with
you more often and getting updates or it
wouldn't have made a difference
i don't think the
decision about going in to
protect the tootsies or not would have
changed
based on who was director he just didn't
want to do that
so if you like this sort of shortcut
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel take care
everybody bye